you tracked down Marv Albert NBA on TNT
Hall of Fame broadcaster and apparently
not going to the bubble Marv thanks for
joining us how you doing good man how
are you your entire crew everybody's
going crazy times how difficult was it
to make that decision to not go to
Orlando to do the games well I was
getting actually very excited about the
challenge
you know after had been discussed how it
will be set up at cetera but I started I
have second thoughts particularly with
the spike recently in Florida and I felt
to be practical you know then I was not
sure what I was going to do and then
Jeff Zucker the president of Warner
media called and we discussed it and he
thought the right move would be to pass
up on it and I agree you know I'd love
to be there but I think in my my age
group there are you know more
possibilities it's a higher risk so but
the new the 79 is the new 78 so I'll be
watching and I hope it gets off I think
that you know the the bubble concept and
the parameters set up by the
Commissioner Adam Silver are on target
but the virus is extremely challenging
particularly in as we all know in
Florida but I wondered I I thought
initially and maybe I misread this with
Kevin Harlan that maybe you guys were
gonna do it from Atlanta broadcast from
there and you know watch the games on a
monitor was that ever a possibility that
was one of the the possibilities and I
think that Turner and ESPN changed their
mind that would bring the me back to my
early days like when I was 11 years old
getting interested in sports
broadcasting I would turn down the sound
on the TV
and I would do it on my woolen sock tape
recorder would be a basketball baseball
I was very versatile at that time and I
actually got a crowd record there was an
announcement less keiter I don't know if
you know that no no yeah he did a lot of
championship fights he did the Knicks
for a year or two then did quite a bit
of basketball in Philadelphia but he
would do recreations the year after the
Dodgers and Giants moved to the west
coast of the games and in in New York
studio on WI NS in New York and would
use the crowd sounds and I did it one
year doing the Syracuse Chiefs in
searches and the road games to save
money were done off a ticker with crowd
sounds and if there was a delay on the
ticker suddenly there might be a slight
rainstorm at the ballpark that actually
did not happen so I thought about people
we might be going back to those days but
no they're hoping you know if all works
out to do it there'll be I guess three
venues and it could be as many as seven
games a day and I I thought you know
before this surge came in Florida I
thought the NBA had the best best chance
best plan I don't know how you feel
about it I think baseball will have a
problem although I got to put the teams
and you know in two regions you know for
example the Mets Yankees Boston Philly
etc but this thing of regular this thing
at hotels and it's you know it's not
going to be the kind of bubble that the
NBA is set up and things can happen even
you know with that bubble and as far as
you know NFL and college football it's a
contact sport I don't know how they got
to pull that off monkey monkey 2 is it's
gonna be tough very tough yeah how many
walk it out but it's gonna be tough how
many NBA games have you called in
career you know I've never counted must
be I made thousands I would guess
five thousand ten thousand probably
about five somewhere in that range
there's maybe a boy what was the
greatest performance you ever called
greatest individual performance you ever
called well for several reasons because
of the condition he was in the Michael
Jordan quote flu or bad Pizza game in
the files against Utah what he
accomplished when you watched him and
you know people the Stan's didn't know
what was happening we were informed that
he was not feeling well he was sick but
he was hunched over he was helped to the
bench constantly and he I don't recall
that you know the the tolls from the box
score but he was extraordinary I've
never seen that type of performance in a
big game I mean I'm sure players have
been ill you know what I played but what
he did under those conditions just to me
is the best performance I've ever seen
but more so because of his of his health
at the time when it was so many between
Michael Brown and Byrd in Eagle right
you know go right through it
while Clyde Frazier Willis Reed back to
those days well you know you bring up
Clyde Frazier we're talking to Marv
Albert I still think that Clyde
Frazier's performance in Game seven
against the Lakers in 1970s one of the
more underrated performances in the
history of the game because Willis Reed
you know I think he scored four points
but the emotional lift and he was named
the MVP of the finals
I think Clyde Frazier put in 36 points
18 assists that sent about right Marv
yeah I think 36 19 and then number six
is six deals yeah
Clyde will agree I do also and I thought
it was an emotional vote because of the
inspirational aspect of what Willis did
he was not supposed to play and he
actually did not play in Game six and
the Knicks got killed
Chamberlain had a big game but Willis
was not supposed to play and walks out
you know the Lakers during a warm-ups
and came out late just before the anthem
and the Lakers just stopped and stared
they couldn't I I never forget
Chamberlain and West
you know just wasn't go over they
couldn't believe he was coming out to
the I mean they were really affected by
that and then he goes out and it was the
loudest crowd I've ever heard at
probably anywhere when he stepped on the
court and I I ended up doing his long
you know a couple of warm-up shots and
there was one nuts when he hit like a
corner jump or you know jumper from the
foul line and then he you know hits his
first two shots limping around the court
you know and just hung in there to
rebound and box out and yeah he didn't
put up the numbers but the rest of the
team and I was a just a great group it
reminds me of well similar to the
Celtics of their great years and the
Lakers and the San Antonio Spurs and the
Warriors the way they move the ball you
know pass the ball a very smart team
similar to all those teams it was Bill
Bradley and Willis and Dave the butcher
and dick Barnett and Clyde and a you
know a couple of guys off the bench he
didn't play many bench players so it
captured New York too because first of
all their first championship and that's
a team that would have would have won
many more had they not had injuries they
won one one other they beat the Lakers
and five a couple years left to that
yeah 73 I think was Willis Reed the MVP
event finals to know he was hurt okay
yeah they had Jerry Lucas that's right
yeah Lange said are they trade them for
Cazzie Russell
but no he didn't get he was on the bench
but he did get the vault yeah I thought
maybe he'd still get it you know yeah
hey you'll be missed but I think you're
making the smart decision there stuff is
it must be for you and it's great to
catch up with you Marv thanks now always
good talking to you I appreciate it
that's Marv Albert Hall of Famer lead
announcer for the NBA on TNT